Okay, so we're going to talk about what I call three phases of chronic line.
So I know anybody that's had chronic line, you well educated yourself.
There's a lot of information on the internet.
You study a lot about chronic line, you feel like you've got a handle on it, but you're
here because maybe there's something else you could learn.
So I apologize in advance if you already know everything that I'm going to say.
But I'd be willing to bet there's going to be something I'll say that will be an enlightenment
to somebody here.
So the first phase of Lyme disease is that acute infection.
So we're not going to get into, is it the Borrelia or the Doropy, is it the colon
infections, is it what?
Because I've never seen a chronic line patient that hasn't had multiple colon infections.
So right now we're going to talk about how to deal with these different phases of chronic
line, how ideal with them in our office, and the treatments that I would suggest in
the doc suggest for a chronic line patient.
Number one in the acute infection stage, I always recommend antibiotics.
The problem is that we don't always know that if we've been acutely effective.
So not everybody gets this perfect bull's eye reaction, not everybody gets this flu-like
symptoms.
And you only recognize that you have Lyme disease when you're already getting a chronic
or later stage.
That's the difficulty.
And thank you to the representative here that's getting things passed so that patients can
be in a acute phase and get into the doctor and say, I think I have Lyme disease, I got this
bull's eye rash, I got this fever, I feel super sick, it's in the middle of the summer,
I don't think I have the flu, and the doctors aren't quite so afraid of giving them an antibiotic
prescription.
Because as you know, if they go, oh, we got to run the Lyme test, which is only about 30% after
it's the first place and they run the Lyme test and it takes three weeks to get back.
You already may have moved past the acute stage.
The acute stage of a Lyme infection is when it is still in a bacteria, it's always a bacteria,
but when it's in a true bacterial phase, a bacteria is the only thing that can be killed by an antibiotic.
The reason why viruses can't be killed by antibiotics is because viruses are smaller and they have
the ability to go inside of a cell.
So normally, if any pathogen, that's anything that you're infected with, goes inside of a cell.
The cell puts up this marker on the outside of the cell, that tells the immune system that
it has been infiltrated and then a macrophage or some white blood cells, it's going to surround
that cell and destroy that entire cell and thereby kill that virus.
So in an environmental infection, you need an immune response to kill it because if you
take antibiotics, antibiotics aren't going to kill a virus.
The problem with Lyme disease is that it's only killable with antibiotics if it's in that
bacterial phase that hasn't yet gone inside of a cell.